cinéma le labyrinthe de pan du mexicain
guillermo de taureaux mercredi prochain
dans les salles un conte peuplé de
monstres et de créatures mythiques dans
une espagne franquiste vu à travers le
regard d'une petite fille reportage
marie-jo jugement et vincent
bouffartigue la promotion du film c'est
plutôt facile mais tous les acteurs
dirigé par le mexicain guillermo del
toro
l'épreuve du tournage a été rude le film
traitant à travers le regard d'une
fillette de l'horreur du fascisme sous
franco divine fait encore des contes de
fées
c'est trop grande trop bien la tête de
ses soutiens comment échapper à un beau
père capitaine de l'armée franquiste un
monstre plus réel et redoutables que
ceux qu'ophelia va côtoyer dans un
mystérieux labyrinthe histoires
fantastiques qui malgré tour fait très
bien la réalité
la dureté de la vie et surtout ce qu'une
petite fille désespérée peut imaginer
une petite fille qui se réfugie dans un
conte de fées peuplé de faune et de
créatures mythiques l'univers du peintre
goya n'est pas loin guillermo del toro
avant d'être cinéaste était spécialiste
des effets spéciaux
c'est hier et s'est proposé de marier la
guerre civile espagnole avec un univers
des êtres fantastiques avec des faits
c'est marrant quand on s'est connus il
m'a dit mais moi mes films ci a pas de
signe pas des poubelles et mon jeu
j'aime pas le cinéaste eu souvent de la
métaphore pour souligner les traces
indélébiles que peut laisser toute
violence physique ou intellectuelle
mon imagination m'aide à survivre dans
ce monde où ce qui compte avant tout
c'est l'argent et le pouvoir de green
browser le grand frère tout ce côté
matériel qui pourrit la vie
c'est terrible au sein de ces images
flamboyante on n'est pas près d'oublier
ce regard innocent sur le monstre
dévorant que peut être le fascisme